no jaywalking on my watch how much would
you need to get started
guess what kind of crime this
surveillance footage is capturing a
contract killing a sex trafficking ring
not even close
after placing ads on Craigslist for home
improvement work agents from California
State License Board went undercover and
busted guys who showed up looking for
work their crime things like painting
and landscaping without a license they
could face five grand in fines and up to
six months in jail during this rate 79
unlicensed contractors got busted and
it's nothing new the agency is always
proudly posting sting footage on YouTube
of course these fellows could get
licensed but it takes them doing your
court date is August 15 a landscape
worker would have to pass a test shell
out four hundred bucks in fees and spend
four years in a state approved
apprenticeship program or getting a
college degree in a related field like
landscape architecture but come on no
cops have better things to do California
has one of the nation's highest
unemployment rates and it's the second
worst state when it comes to idiotic
licensing laws according to this
institute for justice report so instead
of busting those who managed to find
work why not spend more time catching
murderers and rapists who are somewhat
more threatening than painters and
landscapers follow the show on Twitter
submit your nominees next month and
check out Douglas Ephraim in me are you
twittering me